ich will wissen wie es ihnen geht nach
drei monaten corona wie sie wie wir
klarkommen und mit denen sprechen die
nicht knacken
ja es gibt lockerungen ja es gibt
milliardenschwere konjunkturprogramme
aber nicht alle rettet das gastronomen
hoteliers kinder eltern künstler
selbstständige noch kann niemand sagen
wer die krise überstehen wird
das geld ist noch dafür ungefähr 12
monate und dann wird ich will auch
wissen was es mit dem protest gegen die
korona maßnahmen auf sich hat im netz
und auf der straße hat corona das zeug
uns zu spalten aus ihren stimmen ist
dieser film entstanden
[Musik]
corona hat binnen stunden existenzen ins
wanken gebracht und viele menschen die
sich bis dahin vollkommen sicher gefühlt
haben tief erschüttert auch hier im
wohlstand speckgürtel rund um stuttgart
von hier bekam ich eine lange nachricht
die so begann ich bin 54 jahre alt
verheiratet mutter von zwei söhnen seit
einem jahr oma und eigentlich eine
fröhliche und zuversichtliche person bis
mitte märz
[Musik]
beate weber hat sie mir geschrieben
schön hier ist die welt noch in ordnung
ja sagen wir schauen und hoffen die
tropen sorry ich hab mich jetzt durch
seit 18 jahren arbeitet beate weber als
chef rezeptionistin in einem hotel in
der nähe
mit ihrem mann hat sie sich dieses
kleine haus gekauft das noch nicht ganz
abbezahlt ist
sie liebt die natur wandert gerne durch
die schwäbische alb ist mitglied im
liederkranz ein ganz solides leben
mitten in deutschland bis es corona auf
den kopf stellt
können sie sich noch an den tag erinnern
als corona ihr leben verändert hat kann
mich sehr gut erinnern mag ist natürlich
im vorfeld schon besser gehört grüner
dass irgendwas los wir haben das nicht
für uns so in bezug gebracht und dann
kam der tag als binnen einer stunde alle
reservierungen weg waren
die kamen mit ich rein die mails die
sind alle stolpersteine betreffe jetzt
so gänsehaut wenn ich daran denkt
wirklich ja die waren die tage danach
schrecklich schrecklich ich bin einfach
nur bleibt da gesessen und war oft
völlig aufgelöst habe viel geweint muss
ich auch sagen hatten sie so richtig
existenzangst ja ja wir haben noch unser
haus abzubezahlen mein mann ist immer
noch in kurzarbeit
ein sohn des komplett in kurzarbeit der
andere arbeitet zwei tage den monat und
wenn ich mir die hotelbuchung anguckt
den nächsten wochen monate gähnende
leere
ein paar kilometer weiter in können
steht das hotel schwanen 18 jahre lang
ein krisensicherer arbeitgeber für beate
weber
jetzt nicht mehr nicole domo führt es in
der dritten generation ihr mann patrick
ist küchenchef eigentlich jetzt springt
er dort ein wo sonst beate weber sitzt
eine buchung glück förmlich passiert so
was normalerweise zwei von morgens um
sieben bis mitternacht immer und es geht
hier immer das telefon immer eins und
doppelt und eine von dreien geht raus
wir haben jetzt unsere telefon
umgestellt auf unsere privatnummer
wir sitzen
alle 32 mitarbeiter sind in kurzarbeit
die 62 zimmer stehen fast komplett leer
also im grunde eigentlich alles gebucht
und wie sieht es jetzt aus so gut wie
alles mehr
das sind jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mal
zehn oder man gibt er heute 80 jahre
seit 80 jahren gab es und 80 jahren mal
ein belegungsplan vor drei jahren wurde
ein erweiterungsbau gegenüber fertig die
tilgung dafür konnten sie aussetzen
dennoch mehr als 20.000 euro fixkosten
fallen jeden monat an die gesamte hotel
und gastronomiebranche steht mit dem
rücken zur wand
haben sie irgendeine perspektive haben
sie das gefühl zumindest nächstes jahr
im januar februar märz geht es wieder
richtig für uns los im moment eigentlich
gar keine mal da keine perspektive und
das ist das was uns auch so gemacht ich
kann unsere mitarbeiterin gar nichts
vermitteln die mich auch immer wieder
fragen kümmern denn ab september wieder
mehr arbeiten ich kann nicht sagen ich
glaube nein ich glaube das ist ein ganz
harter einschnitt wird der auch über
jahre noch geht und die
perspektivlosigkeit die betrifft nicht
nur die neue chefin sondern dann
natürlich auch in der konsequenz und im
personal- und es macht dann schön angst
die maßnahmen und ihrer folgen waren und
sind noch immer einschneidend sie
gefährden existenzen
die mehrheit der deutschen sagt auch
heute die einschränkungen sind richtig
es gibt aber auch protest
im mai demonstrieren tausende
selbsternannte querdenker auf dem
cannstatter wasen in stuttgart
[Applaus]
ende
[Musik]
und auch auf meinen aufruf hin haben
viele geschrieben dass sie nicht
einverstanden sind
ich fühle mich eingesperrt reform 100
und stillgelegt dieses land wird durch
die überzogenen maßnahmen in den ruin
getrieben
[Musik]
menschen schutzmasken aufzuzwingen die
nichts bringen volksbildung
die meisten die so denken waren nicht
bereit vor der kamera mit mir zu
sprechen
einer aber schon er lud mich ein nach
lippstadt in ostwestfalen
unser rhein ist geheizt ist das denn
jetzt der jochen meyer hallo hallo danke
für die einladung user kein thema dem
hoch los über rein hier hagens mac
gelernter maurer hat später zum
bautechniker umgeschult seit drei jahren
ist er in rente
ich hab mir wochen noch einmal
eingeladen für heute marius müller
westernhagen dass mein mitbewohner ist
ein großer achtung nicht in dieser weise
wird krone nicht wäre hätte ich nächsten
monat am 31 juli mal 50 das konzert in
köln ist 50 konzerte jubiläum
so hawke nina hagen sie haben auf
facebook geschrieben diese verfluchte
masken pflicht lässt mir nur zwei
alternativen wahnsinn oder suizid
richtig was sollte das denn bitte heißt
das sollte das sollte so viel dass unter
das heißt dass mich das vorgebracht
diese dinger wie wenn ich in der stadt
bin war sonst bin ich sehr über all
diese die sie hier nichts mit diesen
masken rumlaufen der vielleicht verrückt
warum ist das ist fürchterlich anblick
und formen das sind die nicht abnehmen
und die können wir in dieses geschäft
gehen sie einmal gehen meinetwegen
machen müsste es ja auch außer ich mache
es ja nicht aber sollen doch völlig
draußen auf der straße nicht andere
leute mit den dingern offen auf nerv
gehen sie machen es nicht gar nicht aber
im laden müssen sie doch nun ist mir
egal ich gehe da reine wer spaß endlich
raus oder hole das ordnungsamt und
tourismus muss man gucken was passiert
weiß ich nicht bis jetzt ist noch nichts
passiert da anzunehmen sich daran
gemacht hat das war jeder tankstelle in
lipperode haben sie haben keine masken
die habe ich nicht was ist so schlimm
daran dass man einfach für zehn minuten
im supermarkt so eine viertel stunde
maximal 20 minuten das ding trinken
danach kann man es ja wieder ab machen
wenn man wieder rauskommt könnte man das
nicht meine vorstellung von leben mit so
einem ding drin
es ist ja erwiesen dass es was bringt ja
gut aber andere sagen wie andere er sagt
anderes android es gibt genug experten
die die da nicht unbedingt für sind ja
unbedingt sagen ja com ist muss sein
also was sind das für experten ich war
auch soziologen und so was jetzt also
alles mögliche schon gelesen also wo
lesen sie das internet bei facebook
heute steht ja genug und von wem ist das
von wem sind diese kommen diese
informationen bei facebook
das sind wir von allen seiten nicht ich
gucke ich unbedingt mal auf die quelle
wie viel zeit verbringen sie auf
facebook viel das ist als letzter aus
erste hat mich mal vor jahren eine
freundin darauf gebracht
seitdem ist das ganz schlimme worden
hagens mac ist 68 leidet an diabetes
eigentlich sollen die masken ja genau
menschen die ihn schützen
[Musik]
ja noch mehr gerne bitte dauer als sie
gehören ja streng genommen auch zur
risikogruppe gehörten risikogruppen klar
haben sie dann selbst gar keine angst
vor garnier mein gott denn erwischt es
mich ich dachte ich bin ganz ich sehe
das ganz pragmatisch ich habe mein leben
beliebt eigentlich und ich will mich
sagte michaud genug ich werde 70 ist ja
aber können sie verstehen dass andere
vielleicht anders sehen das andere
vielleicht sagen ich würde gerne noch 10
20 30 jahre leben
ich bin ein sturer bock ich weiß halt
kann sie ändern
[Musik]
sie sind ja großer bessern haben welcher
song beschreibt denn im moment ihre
gemütslage am besten in dieser corona
zeit lieber um der freiheit würden die
texte text fängt an ungeduld und wut
schleicht sich in eine stadt die
menschen die dort leben haben es so satt
sie wollen nicht mehr führen ihres
führers wort hört sie fluss sagen ja den
tyrannen fort das passt so ja wie passt
das jetzt in die zeit wenn wollen sie
fort jahren die mit merkel zum beispiel
[Musik]
jeden montag läuft hagens mac in
lippstadt bei einem protest spaziergang
gegen die korona politik nutzt zusammen
mit impfgegnern unter anderem corona
rebell sie fluss
[Musik]
knapp 15 sind es heute vor ein paar
wochen waren es noch deutlich mehr
der protest auf den straßen wird leiser
die lockerungen zeigen auch da ihre
wirkung
eine besondere verzweifelte nachricht
erhielt ich aus brandenburg von michael
groß er arbeitet als erzieher in einer
stationären kinder und jugendhilfe
einrichtung ist der bauleiter
die kinder hier werden völlig vergessen
sie leiden und die spätfolgen sind gar
nicht abzusehen
neun kinder und jugendliche leben hier
zusammen in dieser wohngruppe
das jugendamt hat sie aus ihren familien
herausgenommen und doch sind für die
meisten ihre eltern ihre geschwister der
wichtigste bezugspunkt geblieben
regelmäßig dürfen sie nach hause
manchmal ein ganzes wochenende
normalerweise wegen der korona maßnahmen
durften sie ihre familien seit märz
nicht sehen
wir waren die letzten wochen so für dich
während dieser zeit wäre erstmal meisten
vermisst
am pfingstwochenende durften szenen und
die anderen ihre familien das erste mal
seit wochen wieder besuchen
doch das war nur eine ausnahme bin ich
aber froh
sie dürfen zwar mittlerweile von gross
stück runter das ist ein bisschen was
wasser dürfen aber zu den familien
selber hängen wir gerade wieder nicht
schwebe weil die neue verordnung besagt
eigentlich nein warum sind sie denn
eigentlich nicht für ihre kinder das
land brandenburg ist her gegangen und
hat eigentlich uns den die verantwortung
weiter gegeben dass wir entscheiden ob
ihr kind nach hause geht oder nicht
der paragraph sagt ganz klipp und klar
wenn wir erzieher sicherstellen können
dass sie jene vorschriften bei den
familien eingehalten werden dann dürfen
wir die kinder gehen lassen
wie soll ich das überprüfen ich kann das
nicht entscheiden
ich habe aber die verantwortung und was
mache ich jetzt sie wären am ende schuld
wenn sich ihr kind infiziert ja weil ich
habe das ja gehen lassen
die politik lässt den träger mit der
verantwortung und allen möglichen
juristischen konsequenzen allein für
michael groß bedeutet dass er ist gerade
nicht nur erzieher sondern gleichzeitig
betreuer homeschooling lehrer psychologe
und familienersatz in einer person
herr müller war halt das korn zu mehl
am meisten aber leiden die kinder
depressive phasen häufen sich manche
verletzten sich selbst erzählt mir
michael groß abends allein im bett ist
es wohl am schlimmsten
sofia ist die jüngste hier in hohen
neuendorf
zehn jahre ist sie alt sie will ihr
zimmer zeigen
[Musik]
mama papa ich will dass du dich dass du
deine eltern nicht sehen konnte dass
deine mami sehen konnte hat das thema
abend und dann wirst du traurig
[Musik]
michael gross glaubt der keine starke
lobby hat der nicht laut genug ist wird
von der politik nicht gehört
viele die ich getroffen habe denken
ähnlich kinder junge familien solo
selbständige sie fühlen sich allein
gelassen
und dieses gefühl zermürbt
ja wir kommen in deutschland verglichen
mit anderen ländern gut durch die krise
aber eben nicht alle von uns viele sind
verzweifelt viele haben zum ersten mal
in ihrem leben echte existenzängste
das zeigen all die emotionalen
nachrichten die ich bekommen habe so
viel betroffenheit habe ich bislang noch
bei keiner meiner reisen gespürt und
fast alle sagen am meisten zermürbt die
perspektivlosigkeit nicht zu wissen wie
lange sie noch durchhalten müssen und ob
sie es schaffen
die maßnahmen gegen das virus waren
bislang erfolgreich keine frage aber
über die anderen folgen die
kollateralschäden werden wir in den
nächsten monaten noch viel diskutieren
[Musik]